وطالبت جبهه الخلاص المعارضه للرئيس قيس
سعيد طلبت باطلاق سراح رئيس الحكومه
الاسبق علي العريض وشدد رئيس الجبهه احمد
نجيب الشعبي على غياب اي مبررات قانونيه
لاحتجاز العريض وقال ان سببه هو الخيبه
التي اصابت رئيس الجمهوريه بعد نتائج
الانتخابات البرلمانيه
سبب ليس قانون السبب في الخيبه التي
اصابت السيد رئيس الجمهوريه بمناسبه
انتخابات يوم 17 يوم 17 ديسمبر الشعب
التونسي ادارى له ظهره وقال له انا غير
معني بمشارك سياسي وهمي ليس همك همي
الخروج من الازمه الاجتماعيه
فبالتالي
لصرف النظر على هذه الخيبه الكبرى واللي
تصحبها عزل دوليه كبرى لصرف الانذار عن
هذه الحقيقه
ينقل على شخصيه الاولى من الحياه السياسيه
التونسيه مش الناس تنسى شويه ما وقع يوم
السبت